[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors et
apparemment ce jeune homme serait un
deux un nouveau soutien voilà alors vous
j'ai pas d'eau sale sort voilà d'accord
on est où là moi ce que m'inspire mes
images ces images c'est terrifiant et
d'abord je les condamne avec beaucoup de
force parce que c'est une atteinte à la
démocratie et je l'aurais fait pour
n'importe quel candidat voilà et si j'en
fais avec et jean luc mélenchon jean luc
mélenchon gelé dit d'ailleurs j'ai du
respect pour mélenchon aussi l ensemble
à l'assemblée nationale et c'était c'est
un grand orateur est sûre
je moi ce qui m'a choqué bien sûr c'est
la violence mais c'est aussi l'absence
de réaction parce que personne n'a réagi
personne n'a réagi est ce que c'est eric
zemmour donc personne n'a pas cessé vous
dites personnelles que c'est zemmour est
ce que le président la république a
dénoncé est ce qu'un membre du
gouvernement a dénoncé le président l'a
dit oui pour l'instant personne n'a
dénoncé pas un ministre c'est très grave
ce qui s'est passé voilà donc j'espère
qu'il sera et d'actionner le aussi il ya
eu aussi les les agressions sur ce mythe
souhaite racisme voilà beaucoup de gens
tout aussi réagi sur c'est sur ces
agressions voilà donc c'est vrai
qu'après ils peuvent pas réagir ou non
plus oui mais mes sincères excuses ça
excuse pas assurés c'est une équipe
avait eu une arme bien sûr aujourd'hui
c'est
sûr eric zemmour bien sûr il faut faire
attention parce que c'est très grave ce
degré de violence il vous a fait un
petit clin d'oeil lors de son meeting
est ce que est ce que vous pourriez
ainsi un appel du pied même ce que vous
pourriez le rejoindre ou c'est exclu
totalement moi je suis toujours resté
dans ma famille politique et j'y
resterai toujours roulé trop à droite
je sais pas je sais pas j'ai pas de
classement à faire moi je suis
solidement dans ma famille politique je
voulais dit tout à l'heure je suis
sincère dans mes convictions fidèles
dans mes appartenance j'ai été là dans
les pires moments je suis resté jusqu'au
bout avec fuyons j'ai parlé au trocadéro
je suis resté avec sarkozy jusqu'au bout
dans les moments moi je suis annoncé
d'ailleurs que nicolas sarkozy va
soutenir valérie pécresse ou pas oui je
pense souhaité poser c'est est-ce que ça
ça va être un moment important c'est
important pour notre famille politique
c'est déjà
en tout cas ils sont leur relation et je
ne doute pas qu'ils la soutiennent a été
elle a été sa ministre ministre des
universités
elle a fait la réforme des universités
elle a tenu plusieurs mois face aux
manifestations face à la rue voilà je
pense pas qu'il puisse y avoir une autre
solution sincèrement je n'imagine pas
une seconde